[Background noise]
Hi. It's me.
You may be wondering to yourself
"Where am I?", or "Where am me?"
Not you-- me! Where is Markiplier right now?
And you may be also wondering why am I leaning on the bed at such a weird angle.
None of that is important right now
I've got some information to tell you.
And I only know one way to do it properly...
...
...with Stock footage.
[Soothing Music]  My day started like any other
I woke up early,
Before the crack of dawn.
Got out of bed.
Showered,
Brushed my teeth,
And then-- I realized that today was the day
On my calendar it said the day that it was was today
And no other day...
So I packed my bags,
And then flew out the door free as a bird,
Fresh as a flowing river,
--WIDE!!!
[Silence]
[uncertain of what to say next]
And then I hopped on a plane...
Cramped... in the backseats.
I flew, to my destination of the place where I am where you're wondering where I am right now.
And that place ...
Is something so horrible that I can't actually tell you.
But the smarter among you may already know where I am.
Here's a hint:
It rhymes with...
Schmenny schmarbae-bapto...
[he is being serious guys, it rhymes]
And while I'm here, I'm going to be making numerous videos...
Here... where I am.
And you'll see them with your eyes
Or on your television
Or on your mobile device.
But I'm also going to be going on another adventure while I'm here,
To untold lands, far and away.
And there
Who knows what kind of fate I'll meet
What dragons I will slay.
[High-pitched guitar note]
[Three low register guitar notes end the song]
[Shady cult ritual humming noise in the background]
Yeah, I'm in Boston [claps]
Uuuummm...
Sooo...
Here for PAX!
Hehhh!